ce plan c'est le chrono laurent seigne
vous êtes pour oui je suis pour ça ça
fait rire dirait qu'il a retirée on
n'est pas loin de penser différemment
mais alors désolé j'existe ne donne des
arguments
oui des arguments c'est que chaque mètre
carré aujourd'hui ils sont un peu macho
balayeuse ils ont du mal avec les femmes
qui parlent alors aujourd'hui la
situation en france et qu'il y a trop
d'immigration et qu'on n'est pas en
capacité d'intégrer correctement les
immigrés qui sont sur le territoire
alors on peut dire que c'est pas la
vérité j'invite les uns et les autres à
aller voir dans certains quartiers de
paris que les gens dorment dehors ont la
gale ne sont pas nourris des enfants
dorment dehors et je pense que c'est pas
l'honneur de la france que d'en arriver
là il faut pas confondre l'immigration
légale et c'est la question qu'on pose
etes-vous pour ou contre des quotas oui
parce que les français ont le droit de
déterminer par l'intermédiaire de leurs
parlementaires
combien ils sont prêts à accueillir
d'immigrés en france et le droit d'asile
qui est un droit fondamental sur lequel
évidemment il ne faut pas revenir car
toutes les personnes qui sont en danger
dans leur pays doivent trouver refuge en
france le problème sur le droit d'asile
c'est que lorsque les gens rentrent sur
le territoire français même s'ils sont
déboutés du droit d'asile
c'est très difficile de les raccompagner
on peut dire qu'on va mettre des gens
les avions et tout ça mais la réalité
c'est pas ça donc les quotas oui parce
qu'il faut que les français le sentiment
qu'il décide parce que sinon c'est comme
ça qu'on crée du racisme il ya deux
façons de créer du racisme et de faire
monter le front national je conclus un
de ne pas en parler c'est à dire que ce
soit un sujet tabou parce que pendant
longtemps des cons parler d'immigration
noter vous courrez derlot front national
du coup les républicains n'ont pas parlé
jeudi républicain qu'un grand air pas le
parti des républicains et on a laissé la
place au front national qui est monté en
flèche et deuxième façon de faire monter
le front national est le racisme c'est
justement de laisser entrer indéfiniment
des gens et de ne pas s'en occuper et de
créer des crispations dans le pays où
des gens sont amenés à dire vous voyez
moi j'ai une petite retraite où vous
voyez bien sdf dans la rue et alors on
paye des hôtels aux immigrés c'est à ça
qu'il faut pas arriver c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être responsable raisonnable
et gérer l'immigration
jimmy contre parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on parle de sac de patates êtes vous
pour ou contre ce qu'il en faut un peu
plus ou un peu moins j'aime pas qu'on
traite les yeux
comme ça d'autant plus que souvent c'est
des gens qui ont fui la misère la guerre
ou une mort certaine et qui arrivent ici
qu'on traite un peu plus tôt comme des
légumes alors qu'il faudrait statuer
rapidement sur leur sort certains
devront être ramenés chez eux et
d'autres
il faudrait qu'on les a accueillis
dignement moi je suis content pour deux
raisons la première lorsqu'on parle de
quotas en ce moment on manque de
médecins en france on dit que très
clairement il manque de médecins
généralistes de spécialistes et dans les
hôpitaux ce la même chose car on les
récupère de l'étranger dont on comprend
une manoeuvre sous payés on va
déshabiller des pays notamment dans
l'est de l'europe qui vont plus avoir de
médecin qu'on va faire venir ici et en
plus des médecins qui n'ont pas la même
qualité de formation et donc ses quotas
l'avons à mon sens fragilise fragiliser
certains pays et puis deuxième raison
mon père quand il est venu en france
dans les années 70 il n'aurait pas fait
partie des quotas d'immigration si on
les définit kelkal on embrasse il
s'appelle marvin mahmoud ben mahmoud
exactement dans un restaurant et
travailleurs de l'ombre à la 62e l'outil
de travail et aux bisous voila voila et
il a donné deux médecins et un troisième
qui a fait des études supérieures aussi
donc je pense que parfois des gens qui
ne font pas partie des quotas peuvent
s'intégrer peuvent travailler et peuvent
donner une très bonne chose pour la
france
eric quelque chose que je comprends pas
dans ce débat les quotas d'immigration
ça concerne ce qu'on appelle les
professions en tension c'est à dire les
professions pour lesquelles on n'arrive
pas à trouver de français pour le pour
les exercer c'est ça qui est en cause
pas le reste il est passé restions
d'appliquer des quotas aux demandeurs
d'asile il n'est pas question
d'appliquer des quotas au regroupement
familial
donc si on parle de deux choses
complètement de viande si vous me dites
est ce que vous voulez ce qui est par le
projet a cliqué des quotas aux
demandeurs d'asile
non après en effet quand quelqu'un est
déboutée du droit d'asile selon moi il
doit quitter le territoire sinon il est
traité de la même façon que celui qu'ils
obtiendront qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas mais si vous me dites est ce
qu'il faut des quotas oui pour ces
professions qu'on n'arrive pas à
pourvoir oui là là là je suis
entièrement d'accord mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on se trompe un peu de
bonheur qu'il ya quand même pardon de le
dire il ya quand même un projet ou des
projets ou des gens qui veulent le faire
windows 7 pour les migrations légales
with great quand même à la raison de la
crise un questionnaire en ligne
oui je prends première récession en
tension entre plans d'eau comparé vao
comme on va pas entendre tout le monde
sur ce débat je vais je voudrais que
vous répondiez surtout s'il est l'époux
karim zéribi les immigrés à 6 merci je
sais madame peut vous donner la parole
si je suis française mais j'suis pas
nous dépendons
française d'origine oui je suis me crée
on a tous une originaire pas maintenant
moi je suis là mais je suis né à
valparaiso au chili je suis arrivé en
france à l'âge de 14 ans le 8 septembre
ouais c'est bon c'est bon karim et après
c'est nous qu'on va regarder comme des
immigrés l'immigré non êtes vous pour ou
contre des quotas d'immigration
eric a bien fait de dissocier
effectivement la question des migrants
le sort des migrants ne faut pas
confondre de tout ce qui ne devait être
un peu éclairé les migrants
effectivement il ya un droit d'asile il
ya un droit d'humanité de qu'il faut
maintenir dans notre pays parce que
c'est toute la grande de russie de la
france de pouvoir accueillir des gens
qui fuient la guerre ou ou les
persécutions
ça c'est pas le sujet des quotas
d'immigration en fait moi quand
j'entends côté munication j'entends
critères j'entends règles qui sont là
pour gérer les flux migratoires
j'ai pour moi c'est pas des sacs de
patates on l'a toujours fait faut pas
qu'on touche aux consorts de
l'hypocrisie de que quand les maghrébins
ont été appelés sélectionnés par le spf
qui était l'ancien medef à l'époque de
pour venir construire la france les
routes les hlm et compagnie on les a
sélectionnés on a mis en place des
quotas
et on a dit il nous faut tendre
d'immigrés pour construire le pays dans
les travaux publics il nous en faut
autant là donc on l'a toujours fait et
est-ce que c'est scandaleux d'entendre
dire qu'un pays gèrent ces flux
migratoires mais non je veux dire c'est
ça me paraît logique
même les pays du sud moi je suis
d'origine algérienne en algérie on gère
à l'écho les flux migratoires avec
l'afrique subsaharienne mieux à mon nom
on gère toujours une immigration
cantonnés en souveraineté dans son pays
deux mois c'est pas scandaleux après il
faut pas en faire si vous voulez un
chiffon rouge de l'immigration
l'immigration moi ce qui me gêne dans
notre pays dans mon pays qui s'appelle
la phrase qui est un grand pays c'est
qu'on en parle toujours de manière
négative
moi j'aimerais qu'on parle de
l'immigration de manière positive
l'immigration à la porte à la france
aussi à la portée au pays
elle continuera d'apporter du
l'immigration si elle est régulé si elle
est gérée sérieusement et si on ne fait
pas n'importe quoi c'est un plus pour le
pays qu'il faut le vivre
comme tel or aujourd'hui on a ceux qui
voudraient que tout le monde ne puisse
entrer dans le pays sans règles et ceux
qui voudraient que plus personne ne
rentre ce n'est pas ce débat demi
néanmoins il me dérange parce qu'il est
stupide
ils essaient en contenu intellectuel
c'est une conception politique sans
vision politique de la france la france
sans les vagues d'immigration ne serait
pas la france
istres et pagnol italien portugais arme
signé liant maghrébins africains les
juifs qui venait de réaliser la
méditerranée ok italien c'est ce que
j'ai dit j'ai commencé la réalisation et
on voudrait nous faire croire
qu'aujourd'hui il y aura une vague
d'immigration qui gêneraient en fonction
à la religion foutaise c'est des
conneries quand on est allé colonisé
l'afrique pendant 130 2 à la religion ça
gênait personne vois pas pourquoi ça
gène aurait aujourd'hui son qu'on arrête
de créer des problèmes là où il n'y en a
pas vivant ensemble partageant des
règles communes et les quotas c'est
simplement dire voilà qu'est ce que la
france est capable d'accueillir
qu'est-ce qu'elle n'est pas capable
d'accueillir c'est l'idée d'accueillir
aussi convenablement
ça c'est aussi une valeur républicaine
il reste deux minutes je voudrais deux
intervenants raquel à vrai dire quand on
regarde des exemples étrangers les pays
où il ya des quotas sont des pays plutôt
libéraux c'est à dire qu'ils accueillent
plus d'immigrés que la france parce
qu'en fait c'est ça revient une
ouverture des frontières comme ça a été
fait par exemple au canada où par
exemple en australie
mais en france on voit bien que dans le
débat public s'est pas présentée comme
ça ceux qui promeuvent cette dette
quotas veulent dire on est en train de
l'imiter alors qu'en réalité c'est faux
car comme l'a dit eric et pour le coup
je suis d'accord avec lui temps réel
pour les chiens
il ya des trucs qui vont partir qui
mangeait comme ça de pluie de paillettes
évidemment ça concerne et le
regroupement familial n'ont pas compris
ce qu'elle m'a dit tu as puis quand je
suis d'accord avec naulleau ville lui
avec moi tu fais un bouton comme ça mais
ça se reproduira pas vous avez finiront
ce bref bref bref donc tout ça tout ça
c'est beaucoup
comment dire je disais donc le rap le
regroupement familial c'est le cas la
première source d'immigration
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
d'intégrer par le travail parce qu'on a
déjà une liste de métiers sous tension
et même sur cette liste là ça rend au
compte-gouttes moi je laissais ma ma
soeur n'a pas elle est venue en france
est là
un label de musique comme chef
d'entreprise elle a même pas eu la même
pas pu avoir de papiers
elle a dû quitter la france c'est très
très difficile d'immigrés légalement en
france
donc ceux qui disent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés manie assez facilement le
fantasme et ça a une vocation de
politique et moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
me contre parce que je suis pour qu'on
s'occupe des choses importantes
sans remettre en cause notre droit à des
conseils à gérer les flux migratoires
jeu tout à fait d'accord avec ce soit
avec toi là dessus raison pour laquelle
je ne m'étendrai pas davantage
alexis qui a un truc intéressant à dire
en 30 secondes qui est capable de le
faire et rose 30 secondes vas-y moi j'ai
tout simplement si vous nous rejoignez
vous avez vu qu'ils ont pris les
combinaisons d'igor et grichka bandana
mais tu verras ça va le gmi compte tout
simplement parce que c'est un faux débat
aujourd'hui on gère pas les flux
migratoires c'est une bêtise on a à peu
près de cent cinquante mille titres de
séjour délivrés et ça dure depuis un
certain nombre d'années pour moi j'aime
y compte est ce que c'est un faux débat
en revanche j'aimerais que le débat se
soit plus on compte une vraie politique
d'intégration et là pour le coup on fait
des fonds n'est pas capable d'offrir un
logement à tout le monde en france on
n'est pas capable d'offrir un travail à
tout le monde en france et c'est ça
aujourd'hui le la prochaine polémique
bravo oui ou pas
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire c'est la première fois
que je lis gore et grichka les cherry
pour à 64% contre à 36% sur ce sujet